can you tell us about gravitational
lensing technology for a Space Telescope
what are the obstacles and how far away
are we from developed deployed well we
know of gravitational lenses in space
Einstein upon discovering little gravity
bends space hypothesize that a
particular configuration of matter could
bend space in such a way that it can
serve as a cosmic space lens magnifying
stuff behind it in the universe I can't
tell if you're making up science Victor
telling the information from science
because you really like it's that it's
just on the border of like I don't know
it is o-ring powered by will it is all
there and so Einstein made this
prediction it would be seventy years or
so I mean remember my timetables about
70 years before we would discover the
first gravitational lens mm-hmm and
they're all they're all over there kind
of you got to know what you're looking
for because the lens can isn't just
magnify stuff in the background not all
the lenses are perfectly quote shaped to
do what a normal lens would do a summer
like funhouse mirrors so you can take a
background galaxy and flip it left right
up and down distort it and make the
image of the galaxy appear multiple
times because of that lens and so
previously we might have photographed if
I thought it was a separate galaxies it
turns out is one galaxy lens by one
disturbance of space-time creating this
funhouse image so our space telescopes
have found these gravitational lenses
out there in space
these aren't lenses we're making in the
neighborhood right now they're huge
scale and they require a distribution of
mass that we don't have control over
right now so how far how in how many
years do you think we might never know
so around never you do you need you need
the mass distribution what you find in a
cluster of galaxies okay and that's
unlikely but lucky for us
yeah but the Borg could do it for sure
sure yes made up collected certainly
have the resources